You suggest no white bread, thoughts about sourdough.
Well, sourdough has other benefits in it, especially if you're making your own sourdough.
But again, you know, you know, access, carbs like that, you know, are never in favor.
But again, having some sourdough or having some butter, even if you're on a dairy-free diet, like we talked last week,
about a dairy-free diet, you know, could I have a little butter?
Yes, you can.
So, it's about balance.
And so, if you want a piece of sourdough, because you have a piece of sourdough, they're good to say,
because you need a piece of sourdough.
I remember I had a couple of years ago.
He hasn't been on the Zoom for quite a while, but he's still alive.
He was, he, I remember him begging me that if he could just have eat a hamburger, because he was, he had prostate cancer and he was on a,
had issues with glutamate, was a driver until he was on a meat-free diet for the period of time.
And he was sticky, he was dying so well that he would refuse to even ever eat a hamburger.
So, I thought he was going to climb through the fold and kiss me when I told him he could have a hamburger once in a while.
So, it's all about balance, so just keep that in mind.